the black and red blood injected upside
down pentagram sporting satan shoes by
little nazex
as well as his serpent alien satan lap
dancing montero video
could only be released a week before
easter this is business as usual
it has almost become a part of christian
celebrations to expect a few of these
smears
in the mainstream media before important
christian holidays
there's something boring and tedious
about the whole affair
a nicely organized propaganda supply
chain
with just-in-time delivery nonetheless
beyond my first reaction of dismissal
i found that maybe there's something
people might want to understand
in these satanic tropes and these these
satanic moves
nothing none of it is arbitrary but like
any system of meaning
it rather has a strange coherence and
this coherence can give us a few clues
as to why this imagery would be used to
attract the type of attention someone
like little nazex
desperately needs in order to stay
relevant in a post-christian
blase porn infused hungover culture
and i guess i should tip my fedora to
little nas x as he does
a bang up job at weaving all this
imagery succinctly together
but the little nasdaq situation probably
wouldn't have been enough
for me to put any energy into this but
in fact there's a
second angle entering this article this
video
so many people have been telling me to
watch one division which at first i
didn't want to do but i
end up doing it and the ending of this
series lays out imagery that is very
similar to little nazex
and it ends up being like a feminine
witchcraft which contrasts to the more
masculine
satanic imagery in the little nazex
video while nonetheless playing in
similar tones as montero's hellish
carnival
[Music]
this is jonathan pageau welcome to the
symbolic world
so before i get on with this yes yes i
remember the so-called
satanic panic in the 1980s i remember
these pastors telling us about
backtracking and how rock songs had
secret satanic messages
when played backwards but even as a
young teenager i often wondered why they
needed to look for secret messages
when the overt messages were pretty
clear you know
he didn't need the backward ones people
are really bad at hiding what they're
doing
if you pay attention they'll tell you
what they're up to
especially if you know what to watch for
so the montero video is a rather
disturbing sight to behold
in a world inhabited only by virgins of
himself
little nazak sings about his intimate
encounter let's call him and
his obsession with a man who has the
same name as him
montero and call me by your name is the
unofficial title of the song
the video ultimately is about one thing
it's about pride
this self-love is represented as an
exploration of the strangeness and
idiosyncrasies of oneself self-seduction
self-victimizing
self-abasement self-gratification and
ultimately
self-crowning in speaking to his
self-named lover montero tells us that
i'm not fazed only here to sin if eve
ain't in your garden
you know that you can and so pride as
self-love
appears ultimately as a sterile
revolution
against the natural patterns of the
world a desire
for the world to be solipsistic to be
contained
by myself for the world to be in my
image
and a desire to be free from the usual
constraints of
natural patterns and cycles of being
he tells his self-named lover
that he wants to let's say i won't quote
it exactly but let's say to put a child
in his mouth
and this is of course the ultimate image
of sterility
of solipsistic dreaming of this
imagination which is taken up in
fantastical places but does not produce
body
community or cohesion but only causes
revolution
fragmentation and ultimately loneliness
montero tells us that what he wants to
do he wants to do to the ones he
envies and we have entered the pattern
of revolution
of attempting to come up then come in
from behind
so we find montero under the tree of
knowledge in the primordial garden
where he's first frightened but then
seduced by a serpent figure
the serpent figure is a hybrid in the
tradition of renaissance depictions of
the serpent
which have often been linked to lilith
by historians
the hybrid also takes on the imagery of
the alien
so of course this hybrid alien demon
serpent figure
is one that has become the narrative
monster of conspiracy theorists from
david i to q anon
so it could be easy for many to dismiss
all of this as a kind of trolling
and this is indeed the game being played
i think
but there's something else going on
because even if it is just
trolling the question remains why does
montero invoke this very
precise imagery in this video to gain
attention
to provoke to subvert well yes yes
and yes but the error that we might make
is to believe that it stops there
that such a that's such an answer
somehow explains what is actually
happening
but in search of a more subtle
understanding one needs to
ask first of all why these elements
these narrative elements crystallized
the fear is in worry of so many people
at the time they did and then especially
we need to ask why someone like montero
is allowed to embody these fears so
perfectly at this moment
in in order to increase his fame
of course it's about attention but the
reason why certain things will bring you
attention
rather than condemnation or just lack of
interest at certain moments in a cycle
of attention
is not arbitrary at all and
understanding this can help us
understand where we are going in our
social narrative
so whether or not little nazex is an
actual
literal satanist this is something that
i don't have access to
but even the patterns of the stories
that we live and that we tell ourselves
they're not arbitrary and observing them
can help us understand
what is going on
so in the video after his seduction by
the serpent
it follows montessori montero to a kind
of
coliseum where he's chained and judged
by
cross-dressed virgins of himself he's
then stoned by these dusty zombie
figures
that are replicas of him and then he's
finally killed with some disturbing sex
toy so
yeah he ascends into the sky to meet a
shadowy angel
but this pole this pole slash lance
shoots up from below and as montero
grabs it he begins to slide down
in the guise of a pole dancer into the
belly of hell
and let's be honest if there was ever
was a perfect representation of the
let's call it ontological reality of
pole dancing i'm
pretty sure this is it the poll coming
up from below is of course a
an inversion of the sphere of saint
michael which is portrayed in medieval
imagery as
pinning down the great serpent that is
satan coming from above
but now this spear slash poe is coming
to claim montero from behind with all
the
undertones that that also includes
so even though it's coming from below
it's nonetheless the this axis mundi the
axis of the world
it nonetheless is this hierarchy which
connects heaven and earth together
though now it's not a hierarchy scene
from the
the side of the traditional let's say
ladder that you see in
icons of the ladder of divine ascent
which is going up in humility
and worship and self-transformation but
rather it's this coming up
from behind of revolution
and this type of coming up from behind
doesn't end up
being going up in the end it just
actually ends up being a
coming down uh being chased from heaven
which is what you see in the story of
the
the the red dragon in revelation that
uses its tail to
knock down the stars from the sky and
then
then he ends up falling down onto the
earth into the sea and so
it's not the access from the point of
view of the ladder but it's something
like
the this hierarchy from the point of
view of the shoot
or of the serpent sliding down just like
in a
a shoots and ladders game so we see the
movement
from the periphery we see it from the
wheel that's wrapped around the axis
which turns and slithers and seduces on
lookers by its changeability and by
leading them
into their passions so montero is
actually replaying the first part of the
video here
this part where he was seduced by the
serpent which was sliding down the tree
but now
he is the serpent who will slide down in
order to seduce satan himself
so ending up in a caricature of hell
with the thorn covered door which is
nice touch in terms of symbolism uh
montero
lap dances satan into this
simulated sexual act to then himself
come up behind the evil one
to break his neck to steal his horns and
his crown
replacing the devil in what we could
call a final revolution
a revolution which is the supremacy of
the self
so for a satanic story i would say it
actually scores pretty well
so you can imagine that the media
coverage about this little nazak scandal
has been mostly about how
christians are reacting to it how they
are offended
how they're falling into a new satanic
panic
how they're too stupid to see the
provocative humor and the social message
in all of this to me the the potential
message to the youth
in this video is that you can find
strength in being exactly who you are
whoever that is so let's be honest this
is what the whole circus is about it's
about getting attention
like i said at the outset it's not
arbitrary that this image was put out
there just before easter
you see satanism has systematically been
about christianity from
its very beginning and especially modern
pop satanism with all the
contemporary popular imagery out there
from anton levay's celebrity status
and his movie acting to bands like black
sabbath and other forms of
heavy metal satanism all these upside
down crosses the
the black masses the celebration of sin
and of our passions are all about
embodying in a narrative in a
mythological setting
the end of christianity and by embodying
it's the end of its hold
on the mythic narrative or the social
narrative
but secretly and unknowingly it is
restating it but
that's for another time that we could
talk about that
once one understands this many things
will appear to us more clearly
even the ironic aspect of satanism and
cultural provocations like the satanic
shoes
or this montero video you see satanism
is
irony itself you could say from its
ritual version of the black masses to
its more
philosophical social manifestation it is
the christian story restated
from its upside down from its narrative
margin
satanism is something like the gargoyle
as priest the rebel
as king and the theatrics the
joke of satanism is one of the most
important considerations
of its meaning and its purpose and
ultimately of its
satanic qualities so if you ask a levy
style satanist about their religion
they'll tell you that they actually
don't believe in satan
this is of course difficult for
christians who order their lives on
truth and faith to understand
people ask themselves why would they go
to such efforts for something they don't
even believe in
and of course such a reaction comes from
decent
normal you know healthy people who can't
see how there's nothing
more satanic than believing both god and
satan
actually don't exist though all the
while
acting in this self-righteous pride and
resentment
in order to offend christians and
destroy their hierarchy of meanings by
ritually and mythologically embodying
everything that christians
oppose always remember that the montero
video ends with
the putting of the satanic crown on
oneself
all of this is what happened recently in
the whole baphomet statue hubbub
that surrounded the satanic temple in
the united states
in embracing the very ambiguous and
egalitarian american notion of
religious freedom these satanic prancers
are able to show how americans are
potentially satanists because they must
equally
and emphasis unequally include the
parity and opposite
of what most of them believe in in a
traditional world they're the
hierarchy the monsters the demons the
gargoyles and especially
the satan or the opponent are on the
outside
or they're underground they're below us
and it's best to actually not even
pronounce their names
but now in the context of liberty and
equality driving social forms
the figure of satan begins to appear as
a dark prophet of the modern world a
norm
a noble promethean who tragically stood
against
authority and declared himself equal to
that which was
above him in the montero video
little nazex gets it right satanic
imagery has never ultimately been about
worshipping the devil but rather
about embodying the revolutionary
pattern
through the type of pride exemplified by
satan in his war against heaven
and which ends with self-worship and
self-crowning
and obviously it can't really end that
way for
montero's only claim to the crown of
horns is
violence and revolution which means that
there is always another
pole riding lap dancing you know person
in line
waiting to kill montero and to take the
crown from him
but let's just say that that's another
story as well
one of the tropes of the anti-christian
religious scholar of the past decades
has been to point to how idiosyncratic
the devil of pop satanism
actually is the brooding red demon the
horns the trident
the goat-like appearance all of this
they tell us is
just an early modern development which
grew with layers of additions and time
from this horn monster that we see
present in late medieval images of the
last judgment
through these frenzied descriptions of
witches and devils in the malleus
maleficorum
this this malleus is the hammer of
witches which was the famous text
used in early modern witch trials we
moved then to milton's
lucifer and faust mephistopheles
so these pompous religious scholars
remind us that this
figure has little to do with what early
christians believed
and as usual these scholars for all
their factual accuracies
are simply missing the point the
transformation of the evil one from a
shadowy and ambiguous character
in early christian and even jewish
imagination
to the tragic romantic figure he has
become is one of the narrative threads
we could follow to trace the development
of western society
all the way into our present state of
crisis
this narrative development does not end
in milton
but actually continues to grow in
post-militant representations
such as the one we see in neil gaiman's
the season of missed
graphic novel this characterization has
actually become the basis for the
lucifer netflix show so historically
this transformation
actually follows the return to pagan
references
and this this return has been a tool of
revolution from the beginning
it becomes an image of secularism which
informs much of the renaissance
and enlightenment and accelerates into
the modern age
in fact the culminating figure of satan
in popular imagination
this figure that attracted mick jagger's
sympathy
has its president and aeschylus's
prometheus bound
this ancient greek tragedy the titan
punished for bringing
humans knowledge is presented as a noble
resistance
to the tyrannical father and seeing all
this one will come to realize that there
is absolutely nothing arbitrary
about the golden prometheus statue in
rockefeller plaza
all of this follows a narrative thread
which is the very story of modernity
so the reason why the satanic temple
wanted to put up this
stupid image of baphomet in the united
states is believe it or not the
culmination of the same process which
made napoleon bonaparte
fill his ash de triomph with roman gods
and i wonder if napoleon could perceive
that this gesture
of declaring himself emperor while
putting a crown on his own head would
culminate in the solipsistic video
by a pole dancing rapper who seduces the
devil
that to then only kill him and put the
crown on himself
one of the historical moments where we
can trace the origin of modern
occultism and satanism is when the
knights templar were disbanded in the
14th century
the legitimacy of the accusations made
against them is still being discussed
intermittently by historians but in
terms of social narrative
it doesn't matter so much if you believe
the accusations against the templars or
not
it is quite possible that they did not
practice sodomy
they didn't blaspheme against the cross
or worship a strange god named baphomet
in the same vein in terms of what we're
seeing today it doesn't matter if you
believe the accusations against witches
in the early modern period either
of these descriptions of their sabbat
masses and their fornicating with demons
of course one could argue about this in
historical terms and people can do this
interminably until they forget the
original point of why
such an accusation matters what matters
most is how these new possibilities
which appeared at the end of the middle
ages became something like a narrative
space where the opposite of christianity
which was more implicit before began to
explicitly
take form in the form of explicit
sacrilege and
certain types of parody of inversion
and ultimately embracing the opposite of
everything that crashed christians
valued so we mostly need to see these
accusations as a
as an opening up and recognizing of of
certain possibilities
we could call it something like a
narrative space
which showed us the edge and the end of
christianity
and this antichrist was slowly filled as
christianity itself began to falter and
to break apart in the modern age
and it was through these very tools and
this very imagery whether consciously or
unconsciously
that christianity would be attacked by
its own dissidents
it's by these very means that it would
be inverted and subverted
until even these new pseudo-religions
like
satanism and wicca would explicitly take
on identify
and expand the very tropes which were
manifested in those early modern fears
so even if the accusations against the
templars were fabricated
we arrived nonetheless through a strange
process of development through
the enlightenment to the 19th century to
the occultists there like
elephas levi and alice to crowley
through bulgakov
and you know the band slayer we come to
a point where we have this massively
popular
and honestly not at all edgy video which
won
attention for its sacrilege an allusion
to being sodomized by a devil
ultimately the figure of this devil is
itself a combination of this late
medieval baphomet
who haunted the templars in the 14th
century
you see stories have patterns story
stories play themselves
out naturally and once the narrative
elements have been
cast there will always be people events
and organizations to embody them
in a very factual and incarnate way
but the material causes by which this
will happen
are actually quite secondary to their
the more spiritual reasons
you see when christ said judge not let
you be judged
this was not just this finger-wagging
moralizing
he was telling people how reality works
how the projection of our sins unto our
enemies
this focused attention on the sin of
others
opens up the space of our own end
it gives us a glimpse of what is
possible in the story
it gives us a riddle of our own sphinx
and it is by this very sphinx that we
run the danger of being devoured
besides the strange movement from
bafflement to montero
a good example to help people understand
what i'm trying to describe and what is
happening is that
according to the malleus malaficarum
this book about witchcraft that
i mentioned earlier and that was
published in the late
the early modern period according to
this book the
the purpose of witches was to prevent
normal reproductive relationships
between
men and women and doing this out of
resentment
and they accomplish this by several ways
by
for example seducing men away from their
wives by using
disincarnate female demonic phantasm or
succubi so that men would lose their
seed
by making it so women have children from
incubi these demonic males but
actually also through let's say through
the material causes of having
uh children by other men besides their
husbands
and also by killing and harming children
aborting babies
and ultimately yes by removing the male
member
altogether so 200 years ago i might have
been mocked
maybe not even that long ago by the will
to do for suggesting that a group of
people
would want such a thing for the world
and to be honest i can understand why
the
catholic inquisition actually rejected
the contents of this book
and also rejected those that wrote it
and were the proponents of its content
but if we see rather these dark
descriptions
as something like a narrative arc which
is moving towards the end or the
dissolution of christianity
we only have to ponder a moment to
realize that whether it is pornography
artificial insemination whether it's the
proliferation and acceptance of abortion
or even young boys that have been put on
hormone blockers
i can find prominent contemporary
examples of all the
ancient witchcraft i just mentioned
so that the early modern witches might
have been projections or
collective dreams it's possible and you
people will argue either way
is actually not that important to us and
we shouldn't waste our energy on that
what matters now is that these witches
are healthy unabashed and they're
winning the culture war today
so in the show one division which by the
way i will definitely spoil for you now
so
be warned that the scarlet witch a
marvel hero with magic powers
creates a matrix style simulation in a
small town
a safe place in order to preserve and
simulate the artificial existence of her
robot husband
vision vision an ai with a robot body is
the perfect man
the wisest the most moral the most
well-intentioned man
you could ever imagine such a perfect ai
character
a living soul which is actually worth
torturing to preserve
that this is presented to us so
straightforwardly at this
moment in history and with with
everything that's happening with social
media and around us
should already send icy shivers down all
our spines
this simulated world that wanda has
created goes so far as to generate
simulated children her virtual
reality takes on the form of sitcoms
across the decades
but for the inhabitants of the towns
this manifests itself
as mind control the entire town is
controlled and tortured by wanda
into doing her will and playing the
characters in her sitcom but when
they're off screen
the other people in town actually almost
cease to exist
occasionally in the story the spell that
wanda has on them breaks loose for a
moment and we
see these tortured souls peak out
you have to stop her stop whoo she's in
my head
none of it is my own we see them
pleading to be let go
pleading for the incessant pain to stop
pleading at least
for their children to be set free as the
young ones are being controlled by wanda
as well
and all of this for a simulated media
reality
now such a chilling premise can be
imagined in a story where the resentful
supervis
supervillain the totalitarian ai or the
1984 style government is imposing a
false reality and controlling people's
every action and thought so what is
presented in one division is a version
of the matrix but strangely enough
from the point of view of the matrix
itself
the torturer the controller the dictator
is the main character and although what
wanda's doing is presented to us as
being
immoral we're nonetheless called to have
far more compassion for her
and her suffering for having lost this
artificial husband
more compassion for her imaginary
children than we are
supposed to feel for the children and
townspeople she's torturing
all of the supporting characters are
trying to save wanda
and when the zealous leader of the
government team that's there to
deal with the situation tries to kill
her to stop this
he's the one who's presented as the
villain
have fun in prison so yes yes the fact
that
the witch is using media to control the
narrative to torture us all
by imprisoning us and preventing us from
communing with each other
that's a bad thing but one must
understand that the witch has her
reasons
and her reasons what are they they're to
preserve
foster this unholy union with technology
and artificial intelligence they'll
never know what you sacrificed for them
it wouldn't change how they see me
seriously folks this is the actual
premise of the show
there's an insane moment where a mother
pleads with wanda to at least
let her child come out of her room so
that she can take it in her
arms really anything if you could just
let her out of her room
if i could just hold her please i mean i
swear i could almost see the mother in a
medical mask
when i heard this when i was watching
this
at some point i started to ask myself if
this
strange premise was not secretly some
very strange and ingenious argument for
witchburning
i'm sure the malleus maleficorum there
is definitely a section about which is
forcing all reality
to follow their whim in order to avoid
real masculine feminine union
real relationships and ultimately to
preserve artificial men
and solipsistic fantasy children i'm
sure it's there somewhere
i i need to go back there and check
we're joking aside one can easily see
how this is all related
to little nasdaq's montero and his
satanic shoes through a strange mixture
of
victimhood and pride coming together
just as montero populates his own world
with himself obsessed with his
self-named lover
so to wanda has bent all minds to her
own whims and made them expressions of
herself
we feel your pain your grief is
poisoning us
no stop please let us go
so this is truly the place where western
individualism
shows its satanic colors if in american
movies we're used to that scene at the
end
you everybody has seen these where all
the characters in a crowd
you know all the other all the other
characters in the movie usually with a
huge crowd
will applaud the protagonist and the
protagonist is
a stand-in for the individual but mostly
for the underdog
but here in this version we see the
individual with its idiosyncrasies
with all her his their fluid desires
and whims imposing themselves as
something to which all of society
must bend and transform
in montero's hell we see this engraving
and flaming letters
we see the famous latin phrase amnon
quad non-intelligent
which means they condemn that they do
not understand
and what is wanted through these
narrative tropes is ultimately
the opposite of that something like
the misunderstood will condemn them
something like the exception will
invalidate the rule
so if in the christian vision the
shepherd is willing to leave the flock
to even leave it unprotected to go out
and find one lost sheep
here we rather have this lost sheep
demanding that the shepherd
not bring the sheep back to the flock
but rather
bring the entire flock out into the
wilderness
so if in traditional societies we see
this scapegoat mechanism
of sacrificing the exception in order to
preserve coherence
here it is the opposite of that it is a
desire to sacrifice
the entire world for the exception
on a social level this is what appears
as upside down
hierarchies where the strange the impure
the exceptional the fluid the rejected
the sick and the unknown become
not those we need to help but they
become a new measure
by which all of society is evaluated
and so it's only in that sense that the
backtracking fears of my 80s youth
pastor regarding rock music
just like upside down crosses and upside
down pentagram
can make sense as a basic narrative
intuition the intuition
that the satanic like a massive carnival
on the edge and the end of the christian
world
is acting like an evil christian jester
who wants to be king who's turning
mocking
embodying the upside down of
christianity both morally
and ritually what makes him different
from a regular carnival
is that this gesture is also trying to
put the crown
on his own head because of a
consideration for the victim
many of our contemporary social
manifestations can do
christians into thinking that what is
happening is aligned with their values
but stories like juan division can help
us realize
how the very opposite is the case
whether it be the willingness to destroy
our social fabric for the sick
whether it be the advent of woke
victimhood culture and its desire to
make inclusion the purpose for any group
any sports team any church or
corporation
what we're witnessing is the reverse of
christianity
in his book live not by lies rodriguez
points us
to rani g's piercing of this upside down
scapegoat mechanism
as being the driving force of our entire
post-christian society
inciting jihad drear reminds us how
the current process of spiritual
demagoguery and rhetorical
overkill has transformed the concern for
victims
into a totalitarian command and a
permanent inquisition
we are living through a caricatural
ultra-christianity
that tries to escape from the
judeo-christian orbit by
radicalizing the concern for victims in
an anti-christian
manner unquote
it's important to be aware of what is
happening so as to not be duped by
antichrist as christ warned us
but underneath all the scandal all the
sacrilege and reversals there's
actually a secret story happening
through all of this and i've hinted at
it
in my video already
watching someone like little nazak's
mocks deride and invert
our stories to the cheers of the media
and the cultural gatekeepers
we must remember that christ chose judas
who would betray him from within
his inner circle in the same manner our
current situation is part of the story
and the satanic imagery for all its
arrogance and pride exposes in plain
view
the underbelly of modern secularism
and though this imagery appears as a
manifestation of where christians have
failed
it is nonetheless a restating of the
christian story through
attention to its opposite
an upside down world a solipsistic
sterile and artificial world
must inevitably flip back
the glorification even in spiteful jest
of satanic tropes
of rebellion reminds us that it is only
the crucified one and the story of
self-sacrifice
which breaks those unending revolutions
if you enjoyed this content and our
exploration of symbolism
get involved i love to read your
insights and questions in the comments
section
you can also share this video on social
media to your friends
and if you can please consider
supporting us financially
through patreon or paypal you'll find
those links in the description below